so I mean looking at this especially one
picture that I found before before when
I knew who should be and this is this is
this is a picture look at that it's like
you're flying yeah and my first thought
was don't you have a hot yourself
yes actually um a year ago I ruptured my
Achilles tendon 3/4 of it it's quite a
story I was in Italy Sicily and I met
Lenny Kravitz and Lenny was like oh I
would like to dedicate this song to
Michaela de Prince and I oh my god it's
Lenny Kravitz and then so I'm I'm a
clumsy person as well so I was like okay
let me be smart about this I'm gonna
take my heels off and go and sit next to
him on the stage and so I sit like at
the bench underneath the stage I'm just
looking at him like oh I love you so
much and then I get off the seat and
then I like fall into a big dip because
there was at a low tempo and old temples
are unfortunately uneven and I knew
right away I was like oh I ruptured my
Achilles I went to my age and I said I
have to go to the hospital you're
Kelley's doing that you did it I know I
know I know I know as opposed yeah
you're professional at that yeah and you
would child number 27 not be Kyla yeah
he was child number 27 well I was number
27 and my original name is mobility and
the thing is I had vitiligo I was born
with the skin condition and in West
Africa they thought because of my vision
which is the why it's the white spots
yeah it was more pronounced when I was
younger because I was very malnourished
after losing both my parents my uncle
brought me to the orphanage
nor furnish they ranked us from one is a
favored child number 27 is the least
favorite and because of my spots they
called me the devil child the devil
child
yeah they thought anything that happened
anything that was wrong was my fault
that I caused it to happen if it was
refuting get enough crops if you if the
rain did
come that year if it was my fault
because it was very spiritual and you
would think that you know all these
children we've lost our families you
would think these women that were taking
care of us would show us love and
nurture us and care for us but instead
they just treated it treated me like the
devil shop and then my best friend who
was number 26 because she was
left-handed and she didn't choose to be
born left-handed I didn't so beware
being ranked solo yeah what what did
that lead to I mean did you did you have
to did you get the same food as the
others or did you know I got smaller
portion of food I got the last choice of
the clothing pile I was
yeah they remember they told me we would
want to adopt the devil child I wasn't
gonna get adopted but luckily enough
because my best friend had the exact
same name my mom my mom now she was
looking online and she said and she
called the agency and she said oh I'd
like to adopt infinty and they said well
which one Levin see but and so then they
my mom realized there is another my
Benji they're like yeah we have to and
they explained that nobody wanted me
because of my ass paucity they thought
you know to have issues and insecurities
so they didn't want to deal with that
but that my mom was like I will take her
[Applause]
when did you first discover ballet
because in war-torn Sierra Leone oh
there wasn't much ballet was there is no
ballet all I mean of course it's a it's
a very cultural it's a lot of music a
lot of dancing different things but I
never saw ballet before and so this
magazine I found in Sierra Leone it was
ten years after this magazine was
published and on the cover was a
ballerina
her name is Maggie mess sack it took us
maybe 12 to 15 years to find out who she
was but I saw I saw this person but it
could have been a tennis player could
have been anybody was she looked happy
and as this was in the orphanage in the
orphanage yeah and I was four years old
and so in this time it wasn't the tutu
it wasn't this I mean it was cool like
she was you she look very pretty but she
looks so happy and I want to know what
that felt like
so I thought okay I'm gonna be exactly
like her and this way I would be happy
too
and you keep that with you yeah I ripped
the cover off and it's pretty gross but
I put it in my underwear because I was
the only place I could put it and when I
got adopted I tried to explain to my mom
why my adopted mom why I was looking
through her luggage so I assumed okay
American mothers are gonna have
everything right your tutu your tiara
your pointe shoes it's automatic but so
it was looking through everything and
then the only way I could explain to her
what I was looking for was to show her
that picture the most precious thing
that I had just to give it her and she
understood right away so then she wanted
to help you yeah you coming yeah I would
dance but before that I mean you you
grew up in a very different part of the
world and you come with your now sister
mm-hmm
and you you you you come to to us can
you remember your first impression can
you remember that what what that was
like I mean going to the grocery store
for the first time was incredible I had
never seen that was my I think my
favorite part was the fact that in in
the orphanage we didn't have food we
didn't have a lot of food in the food
that we got was not very good at all was
mostly rice or beans but when I went to
super my favorite thing that I grabbed
the first thing was grapes
I had never tasted anything like that it
was an absolutely amazing and also I
didn't know that you had to pay for it
so I just was yeah it was it was a bit
of a shock and then also like my family
were quite big they're nine of us
adopted six from West Africa two from
the Philippines and one from the States
and the reason why I've got adopt is
because Michael my three my brother's
had HIV and AIDS and so Michael before
he passed away he begged my parents to
adopt a child from West Africa so in his
honor that's what they did but to go
into a place that's why you have your
name as well yeah Michaela Mia Mario
were all MS but to [__] going to a place
where all of a sudden everybody loves
you you're you're wondering why but I
thought I was this monster why would you
think why would you love me because I
look horrible I thought I look like a
monster because of what they told me but
it was amazing the amount of love and
every it was and the things that my mom
would make us the amount of food that
yeah I I feel like a business where
you're able to receive that kind of love
from the start or was it difficult to
difficult transition it was very
difficult it took me some time because
as a child because of the PTSD I thought
I was still in Sierra Leone so every
single time I'd go to bed I would be
scared to wake up and be back in Sierra
Leone because you've experienced some
terrible things yeah and so I would be
so scared to fall asleep and and when I
would fall asleep I'd relive the
nightmares that I had in Sierra Leone
constantly every single night and it
took me a few years to finally believe I
was in the States that I wasn't gonna
wake up and be back in the orphanage
okay can you still have nightmares yeah
I was diagnosed officially almost two
years ago with PTSD to the point where I
was so distinct that I just was on
autopilot wasn't sleeping at night I was
terrified I was very hypersensitive but
I went to a therapist and started to
EMDR which is a rapid eye movement and
it is incredible it's not just that I
just I I I went to therapists I talked
about my problems I didn't pretend that
I didn't have this issue I finally gave
myself a chance to heal and that was the
biggest achievement I think I've
accomplished so that's held yeah
definitely becoming a dancer a ballet
but as always as you are it's not an
easy way I mean even though you have the
support from from home it's a very this
is a very white art form
yeah unfortunately and I know you made a
point of that yeah in a way it has that
been difficult for you well the thing is
when you see somebody on TV and they
look like you you think you can
accomplish something I didn't see that
so I was very worried and I did have a
few people like there is Heidi Cruz from
Pennsylvania Ballet who was very
supportive and especially when I was
getting ready to do this role I was so
excited everybody knows a Nutcracker
right
and I was getting ready to do Murray I
was rehearsing and rehearsing and then I
overheard my teacher saying oh she's not
gonna do because America is not ready
for a black Murray hmm I was a little
child I was so excited to achieve this
I'm you had to be the lead in the
Nutcracker and this is when I started to
realize oh this is gonna be so hard and
of course sometimes I was like okay this
is just not worth it I there's nobody
else out there like me there's there was
like maybe five five principal dancers
that I knew that were african-american
and then I saw everybody else and I was
like okay and is this really worth it is
it really worth feeling like I don't
belong all the time that I have to not
eat because I need to be just as skinny
as those other girls that you know I was
constantly discriminated against because
of the fact that I was a certain color
and it wasn't just that in ballet it was
also my outside life as well so when I
went to go and do something that I love
so much I was discriminated against
because of it it was yeah but also I'd
like to prove people wrong so try to
prove them wrong
how old were you at this time when you
overheard them saying that you couldn't
do the lead part in the night around 8
to 10 yeah
and that was just the beginning that was
and your support from the government or
us your parents my parents and it's the
arts is such a beautiful thing is so
historical that and it's so expensive to
do something so incredible and -
especially for children like me my
family the Arts has helped like it has
saved us and has helped us find a way to
express ourselves my sisters are singers
pianists she can play the oboe art if we
didn't have that I don't know how we
would be or who we would be right now do
you feel like you've passed the point of
being the black ballet dancer and just
become this super amazing ballet dancer
is that even something you're striving
for
yes I'm because the thing is I talk
about I'm like saying I'm a black ballet
dancer bat ballerina
you don't doctor doesn't say I'm a black
doctor exactly of that pilot yeah and
you have to constantly have to say this
because there aren't black ballerinas
and these children like you're saying oh
we want to make the companies more
diverse but if you're discriminating
children who are different yeah how are
you gonna make anything different
because even the clothes for a ballerina
yeah made for white people yes exactly
but now I just helped a brand called
gainer Minden as a point shoe brand also
freed London as well came out with brown
pointe shoes so in 2017 gatorman came
out with a very first pair of brown
pointe shoes I now wear brown pointe
shoes on stage and brown tights as well
and I feel like myself it's not two
different people I just always felt like
like I couldn't stand like I couldn't be
proud of dancing on stage I couldn't I
wasn't a hundred percent there you've
you've also done performed in a video by
Beyonce yes I was pretty cool too that's
very cool so I guess that was nice and
also Madonna is gonna do a film about
you yeah
she's directing my life story my little
life but yeah my life story I would say
well I would say lucky heart project but
but the where you have found where you
mother found I mean yeah I've have not
to put this in a way but I have a lot of
gay friends and that's why I knew about
Madonna and her music and but when I met
Madonna
it wasn't she is so incredible and so
like she does her she does it her way
and that inspired me to do my way the
way I want to do it the way yeah not the
way everybody else is doing I want to be
able to leave a mark and that is what
she's doing and she so I mean she is so
intelligent and just so like yeah she
doesn't take Shh from anybody I believe
this is survey that is be successful
that you go your own way and follow not
another if a father other this way we
talk about Norwich's
[Applause]
but I say to the Swedes I come 95 there
and I said if we follow Norway we never
beats him
we are always number 2 and this I think
it's in everything follow your dreams
exactly to what you like it doesn't
matter what it's a good carpenter has
also a good life
he also and this is what I prefer for my
life that I live in a dream and you live
in a dream and you live in a dream and
you live in a dream you have the hardest
life from us but the people fight
against your path this is this I think
the secret of a good life doing it your
way it doesn't matter how successful but
you have to follow this is what you like
I think with those words I think we
should let you take the stage because
your bad is waiting for you
oh yes daddy thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
new trailers thank you so much for
sharing your story here before you do it
with Madonna thank you I really
appreciate that
I'm good luck with everything
thank you so much hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe